one and a half million households
apparently facing a rise in energy bills
um more could be at risk uh is what we
were hearing from quasi quoting actually
when he was sat just there the other day
um
we're told that energy prices will
remain exceptionally high during this
winter
will they
well we know that there are um
extraordinary set of circumstances that
have built up with
increased demand in asia with the fire
in ashford
that's caused issues around getting gas
over from france but the majority of our
um
uh energy actually is developed
domestically and with norway about 80
between those two and so we're
concentrating on prices we're making
sure that uh we have that uh supplier of
last resort when the when companies are
leaving the market so that consumers can
be um transferred the energy price cap
is is is clearly keeping prices down um
even with those upward pressures for so
many people um and consumers around
around around the country but those are
artificially low prices aren't they and
that is reviewed every six months that
price cap and that is undoubtedly going
to go up
well yeah i mean there are clearly
pressures on that but what it's still
doing what the energy price cap is still
doing it's still reducing uh prices or
the the cap fought for for for uh
millions of people across the country by
around 100 pounds um up to 100 pounds
depending on if it's single fuel or dual
foot fuel but yes off gem that we've
we've had lots of conversations the
secretary of state has with companies
themselves with uh off gem who in
reviewing that price cap is clearly
going to uh know that we want to protect
customers not just their supply but
clearly their prices as well what's your
worst case scenario about how much that
price cut will have to go up in the next
six months well as i say that this is
all part of these conversations because
the the thing is we haven't even thought
about it well the thing is the the whole
part part of the conversation is that
off gen um well we'll set will set that
cap out because supply um prices are
based on a number of factors uh and
clearly as government we need to uh make
sure that we're planning for the worst
case scenario because we want to make
sure what is the worst that we can we
can protect consumers well this is what
we're dealing with with gas companies
with energy companies and off gem at the
moment secretary of state has been in
pretty well back-to-back convert
conversations with them over the weekend
and throughout this week to make sure
that we can plan for the you know so
what is the worst case scenario for the
price gap well that it goes on for
longer than than a short than a short
spike and this is why what does that
look like like in pounds what does that
look like militarily for people who are
already struggling
i think that that will develop i can't
give you a figure now because as i say
that's that's really subjective the
reason i ask you is because the uh
joseph ranchery foundation can give us
um a figure and as far as they're
concerned they're looking at their
figures and they say 1
750 pounds is how much the cost of
living
crisis is going to increase for families
who can least afford it yeah i think
what you're looking at there we were
talking about this yesterday is this is
uh that there's a wider piece of work
that they're doing they're looking at
they're looking at the cost of living in
general what the conversations that i
was talking about specifically
yeah
that is fuel especially at this time of
year you have to accept that oh
absolutely no absolutely so they can
come up with a figure so why can't
but as i say that figure that they've
come up with is is a rounded figure with
a number of factors it's not just
talking about energy and they've made
some assumptions in that but we want to
make sure we we have to we have the very
best evidence from off gem from the
energy companies who are basically the
it's the energy companies that are
setting their um wholesale prices or
buying at wholesale prices so they're
the ones that are going to inform us of
how we're going to move given that
you're aware of of what they have been
saying um you know they're saying that
the cost of living as far as fuel is
concerned me is a can be comparable to
what um hard pushed families spend on
clothing and shoes for their kids yeah
look i think i come back to the point
we've we've got the warm house um homes
discount uh for for the lowest paid for
people on certain aspects of pension
credit as well who will automatically
get that we have the winter fuel payment
we have the cold weather payment as well
but that energy price cap as i say is
still reducing prices by um by up to 100
pounds for dual fuel use the universal
credit payment
what we gonna do about that well i think
you guys are going to lose face so you
might as well just do it now look well
again you know the labour party were
pushing this yesterday without any
answers about how it's going to be paid
for because the universal credit it was
there to default um an emergency
situation over the pandemonium
situation well the the the chancellor
would clearly look at the whole gamut of
public finance so it is something
i'm not saying about the universal
credit because i'm not the chancellor
but he'll look at would you pressure
you'll look at the whole look at it
again
he'll look at the whole aspect of public
finance is in the budget and the
spending review that is coming up
but uh if you if you were to reverse the
universal credit as it is you have to
put income tax up by a pe the equivalent
of putting income tax up by a penny and
so you're saying it's something three
pence on fuel get rid of the universal
credit or put a penny on it you have to
find six billion pounds don't you think
that most people would accept putting a
penny on income tax so that people can
put food in their kids bellies and shoes
on their feet and heat their homes it's
not one or the other well no what i'm
saying is that you you have to find six
billion pounds from somewhere and
actually what you don't want to be doing
for the lowest paid in particular is is
giving with one hand and taking in
increased taxes
impacts on the top five percent most
absolutely doesn't absolutely it's
in these crisis situations to be helping
people who need the money well as i say
the budget takes cut it takes takes into
account the public finances at the
moment what we what we're doing we are
we're increasing the national living
wage we've we've increased um income for
uh by about four thousand people for
four thousand pounds per year for the
lowest paid in our um uh in our society
that's something that fits within my
remit we are increasing wages as well
we've seen wages going up quite rapidly
in some sectors as well
no no we're not
we're seeing it sorry i should have said
we're seeing that going up in quite
rapidly and some sectors that have been
underpaid for some time now and that's
very much to be welcomed we want to also
encourage people and find out what we
can do more to
link the the uh record amount of
vacancies to people that are out there
universal credit if i may we understand
all of those and you know we talk about
it a lot in general yeah and the
universal credit is an easy win for you
it would mean uh
the world to the people who need it most
and if the government says you know what
we've listened to you people who are
voting for us uh on the red wall and as
a res behind the red wall and as a
result yeah we are going to keep it for
another year at least this is something
that we're looking at for the country as
a whole it's not red wall blue wall or
any sort of political aspect it's making
it it's making sure that we we're doing
the right thing for people across the
country especially the lowest paid
in in the country and one of the areas
we're looking at doing at the moment is
reviewing the national minimum wage and
the national living wage that's coming
up for
consideration uh this year and we'll
take the view from the low pay
commission and what more we can do on
there to meet and manifest that you're
sticking with universal credit being
scrapped well as i say it was emergency
measure that did its job at the
particular time but the chancellor will
look at public finances and look at the
the cost of living in his budget in the
spending review coming up it gets worse
um we're hearing from um tesco they're
saying the boss at tesco is saying that
shells could be 10 times worse they're
empty already they could be 10 times
worse
before christmas and that is because we
haven't got enough delivery drivers to
deliver the food around yeah so we're
doing uh there is a global issue
actually it's not just a uk problem
there's uh poland and something like 120
000 htv drivers short germany 45 000
there were issues in canada and
elsewhere as well other countries so we
don't care about that no but i've got it
but i'm just saying the fact that they
can't buy stuff because the shelves
aren't absolutely and i was we were in a
cross-government meeting yesterday
talking about it we're talking about a
regular basis what more we can do and so
well one of the things that we're doing
is there are a number of people there
are hundreds of thousands of people in
the country that have hgv licenses
either full or partial that are not
working at the moment how we can
encourage them back how we can increase
the number of tests to get more people
through the system which has been
delayed because of the pandemic and the
changes that department transport have
made
will result in about 50 000
new tests over the years but starting
from now so we can start to get them
within the system within the system
there's an easy fix according to um our
man from tesco he says 14 000 hdv
drivers left in the year to june 2020
only 600 have returned what we need is a
temporary amnesty for bringing foreign
workers back which is why i started off
talking about the fact that this is is
that something we're looking at this is
why i started talking about the fact
that this is in in other countries
because actually there's no guarantee if
you've got a shortage in poland if
you've got a shortage in germany and
other countries around the eu my
question is should there be another
there's no guarantee that actually if
you start something you should if you
start opening up a route that actually
people will come back in as as the
person from tesco's assumes um but
clearly we'll look at all options in
terms of short term uh issues the longer
term and the medium term uh is something
that the sector will work through but we
will help them do that by making sure
that we can get more hgv drivers um in
the pipeline you're saying it is
something that you would look at to have
a temporary amnesty bringing drugs
overseas no i think the the one of the
issues with temporary embassies and and
issuing new visa routes that actually
takes weeks and months to open anyway
so it's not it doesn't quite work that
way so by the time you've got you're the
government you're in charge no by the
time you've got systems in the these do
take weeks and months to open anyway um
and so actually the the
again it's not quite the the panacea uh
that you're so you're saying no
it's off the table
we don't take anything off the table but
nonetheless uh what this is why we're
looking across government to make sure
that we can and with the sectors that
are most involved to see what we can
come up with both short term and in the
longer term here to talk about working
from home um and who it's a good idea
for
yeah and it's uh
we so we're making uh consulting on
making flexible working the default
option that people can request to work
flexibly that's not just working from
home it's become known as working from
home during the pandemic this hybrid
working but it might be actually
compressing your hours it might be
working core time but having flexible
time start and finish times which is
brilliant for caring it's brilliant for
child care in particular and other
people to give them the flexibility and
what that
results in is a happier workforce a more
flexible workforce
and actually tends to lead to more
applicants
coming into
job vacancies in companies that offer
that kind of flexibility but everybody's
on board though duncan smith says that
civil servants need to get off their
backs and get back to work yeah that's
about the return to work that's that
simple binary thing about thinking
flexible working is all about whether
you're working from home permanently
because basically permanently permanent
working up from home is living at work
i've done that myself when i was
self-employed uh and it's it's a novel
idea for a little while so yes we do you
know we want to encourage people back to
the workplace it's not going to be
necessary
the nine to five five days a week in
every workplace but it's up to employers
and employees to have a a good
discussion that that actually works for
both because it you can't have flexible
working in every single workplace but
nonetheless as i say if you get it right
you get a better work better workforce a
happier workforce and ultimately a more
productive workforce just before i let
you go um we've certainly had lots of
doom and gloom during our interview um
today a lot of parents are thinking you
know what i need to take my kids away
for half term if i can possibly afford
it these pesky pcr tests cost a flipping
fortune
are we going to scrap them and if we are
are we going to scrap them in time for a
half turn uh that's absolutely the aim
we've got to get again systems in place
because we want to move to a lateral
flow test
to make it easier and cheaper for people
to be able to enjoy those holidays at
half time but hopefully by half time uh
that's that's the the aim is uh later on
in october so uh so we you know we know
that half term is looming we know that
people want to get away but we also want
to encourage business travel as well
because that's investment in the uk it's
investment in jobs and creating
opportunities for people